You know, everybody, we're going to record a little session on the Zoom call.
Michelle was having trouble with the settings, and I want to make sure we are all on the
same picture with the settings.
So it doesn't accidentally get changed or when we try to fiddle with it, it gets changed
and then we can't figure out what's going on.
So when we are looking at the Zoom call, you can see that page here, your managing participants
don't have anybody in the participants here because I didn't share this with anybody.
So nobody is on the call, but you could mute everybody.
You could unmute everybody, and then you could click here that you can lock meetings so
that nobody can jump on.
You could mute participants on entry, and this might be a big one when you're doing a Zoom
call so that when people enter that you're in the middle of something, you're in the middle
of a talk, and somebody is entering the Zoom call, 10 minutes late, and they're clay-eat-dishes
and stuff, and you're trying to figure out, you know, in this box here when it has all
the other people in here, you're trying to figure out who it is, it's clay-eat-dishes
to mute them.
I have to do that multiple times.
One of the ways that you can do that is by looking at the screen, you'll see all the other
names here, and when you see this, this symbol right here, the mic, now Biden is going
up and down right now because it's receiving my sound from my mic here.
Most other people's, even if they're not muted, if they're quiet, there will not be a green
side of that going up and down because they're quiet, and one of the ways you can tell that
static or feedback or sound in the background, who it's coming from, is by going down your
participant list here and see who's mic is unlike that, and it's making sound like that,
so that you can just mute them.
You know, you can go down and just, as you continue to talk, you can mute them while you're
doing that, or you can hit mute all again, so that you can continue to talk, but that's
one thing that I have to do multiple times to set up.
Mute all when we start, and maybe there are six people on there when we start, five minutes
into the Zoom call, somebody else jumps out, or two other people jump on, or three other
people jump on, and then there's all the static background always, well, you can just go
down here, and hit mute all again, so it just mutes those new three people that just jump
down, or you can look at that little symbol and mute that person, that's what you have to
do individually, if someone's asking a question, and somebody jumps on the Zoom call, and it
starts talking the background, but also you can click this more thing, and hit mute participants
on entry, but then you have to make sure that you unmute everybody when you open it up
for questions, and then you would unmute all by this, but if you click this mute participants
on entry, then everybody on entry is going to be muted, and they will be able to talk to
you, so of course, if you don't want to one-to-one, you would have to do that.
The other things that information on here that are helpful is this pull-down right here,
this pull-down right here, this is the mistake that Michelle was making, is that the
select a microphone, we want this microphone selected right there, that's my new mic that's
sitting on my desk, if I put a built-in microphone, that's the microphone from the computer, which
is fine too, but it doesn't give us clear a resonance, better back, here's the built-in microphone,
you can hear me right now, here's this microphone, now that's selected, you probably have a little
bit better sound, I don't know, but that's the new microphone that we have, this is the one that
Michelle was having trouble, is that select a speaker, so this is where you hear the person,
you can't select the microphone as the speaker, this was selected, I don't know how that
got selected, now if you are speaking, I wouldn't be able to hear anything that you're saying,
so you have to have built-in output, that one selected right there, that's the speakers of the
computer itself, or if I was using a headset, it would show up on here, I don't have a headset
plugged in, so it's not showing up on here, and if I had a headset plugged in and I could click that,
I'm using a headset, so you have to look at this little pull-down here, where's your sound coming
from, where's your microphone coming from, which microphone are you using, which speaker are you
using, so that you can hear the people, so make sure that that is checked on that audio settings,
and then of course, when you're going to record, you hit record out, there's no record button here,
because I've been in the process of recording, but I could pause the recording, stop recording, and
beat it, and change my share, I'm sharing the whole screen right here, all right, so hopefully this helps,
and I'm going to post it out.